talking about jon jones yeah how jon
jones is fighting this weekend
jon jones is a wild [ __ ] and
that's why
he's the greatest light heavyweight of
all time because he's so it's part of
what you have
you have to have it we're talking about
going being with mike tyson
mike tyson back in the day you couldn't
that's why
when people say like why does mike tyso
first of all he's a fighter he's not a
tennis player
but mike was a wild boy and
to hang out with him you could
understand
like he was the biggest person on the
planet and he had the demons
you know what i'm saying and but he's
fun too because because you see him in a
club and you see
he sees some girls hi how you doing
you like bmws what do you like you like
bmw
like i like bmw and crazy he'd take the
girls out and
go get a bmw i mean he was that crazy
you know what i'm saying justin come on
come on let's look at the b and open up
the bmw dealership
but he was wild but i say just like how
we were saying off here
you can't have that type of
talent in that area and not have
jon jones can't you you can't you can't
drink milk and
and almost kill somebody you know what
i'm saying you can't yo let me get that
homogenized
i'm about to go no you can't yeah
there's got to be something about you
that's out of control
impulsive wild dangerous and that's what
makes him so great
everybody you even talked about you look
at the people on your wall you look at
hendricks you look at elvis they have to
have something
because that's god [ __ ] with us yeah
god's going to give you something
incredible
but he's also going to give you
something to anchor that because i
believe
this is what i believe in and you tell
me if you believe this i believe in the
yin and the yang of everything meaning
like
when there's absolute light there has to
be absolute darkness
to balance it out and that's what
everything that we do it's sort of like
we're not gonna get away
with anything like anything that happens
to you in life
you have to pay for it like i it's like
the grocery store okay i got the career
gotta pay for that okay i got the money
boom okay i gotta pay for that
then here come the family yeah i need
that money
yeah you you [ __ ] i'm go i'm going
i'm gonna release a story about you
so it's all of these different things
that you got to pay for and that's why
you see these guys like that because
you know like i said talking to justin
bieber you know everything i said some
of this [ __ ] is supposed to happen to
you
it has to